has the PlayStation 5 Slim been revealed
plus nvidia's new expensive graphics
cards new cyberpunk updates for them and
yet another Marvel game announcement all
on today's Gamespot news
a new version of the PlayStation 5 will
be released in 2023 featuring a
detachable disk drive according to a new
report from Tom Henderson at Insider
gaming sources told the site that this
new model of the PS5 has been in
production since the PS5 launched in
November 2020. the new remodel will
reportedly feature a detachable disk
drive and will connect to the PS5 via a
USBC port on the back of the console the
site went on to claim that the PS5 will
be sold on its own or in a bundle with
the detachable disk drive while these
rumored disk drives will be made
available for sale separately the new
PS5 model is said to be quote Slimmer
and lighter than the current system the
report had no mention of pricing if that
wasn't enough hardware for you Nvidia
finally unveiled their 4000 series cards
and while they're not cheap the RTX 4090
is nvidia's new flagship GPU shipping
with 24 gigabytes of gddr6x memory
Nvidia claims that it will be able to
deliver frame rates higher than 150 PS
when gaming at 4K all while consuming
the same amount of power as the RTX 3090
TI using DLS S3 the latest version of
nvidia's AI based up resin Tech Nvidia
says that the RTX 1490 sees four times
more performance than the RTX 3090 TI
using dlss2 the RTX 4090 starts at
1599 and Launches on October 12th the
RTX 4080 is launching in two different
configurations a 12 gigabyte
configuration and a 16 gigabyte one
Nvidia claims even the lower and 12
gigabyte card can outperform the 3090 TI
when utilizing dlss 3. the 16 gigabyte
model starts at 11.99 while the 12
gigabyte version starts at 8.99 both
will launch sometime in November to show
off nvidia's fancy new cards in dlss
Tech a new version of portal is coming
out called portal RTX it'll be a free
update for owners of the game on Steam
in November and will work on any RTX
card despite DLS S3 being exclusive to
the 4000 series GP use and video will
also be releasing a new modding tool
called RTX remix that allows modders to
easily bring RTX enhancements like upres
textures and Ray tracing to older titles
Elder Scrolls through Morrowind used as
an example in the reveal showcase if you
want to check out these new cards with a
more recent release cyberpunk is getting
a 4000 series makeover DLS S3 will allow
for a new overdrive Ray tracing mode
that'll make the regular old boring Ray
tracing mode on your stupid crappy
current RTX GPU look like you're playing
the game in 1977 not 2077. another game
that will likely run beautifully on
those beefy new cars is EA motives new
Iron Man game EA announced to the motive
Studios the developers behind Star Wars
squadrons and the upcoming Dead Space
remake is making a single player
action-adventure game starring the
Marvel hero it will feature quote an
original narrative that Taps into the
rich history of Iron Man channeling the
complexity Charisma and creative genius
of Tony Stark and enabling players to
feel what it's like to truly play as
Iron Man the studio recently added idos
Montreal Alum Olivia Prue who worked on
last year's Guardians of the Galaxy game
published by Square Enix who will lead
this new project seriously if you
haven't played Guardians of the Galaxy
yet do it it's really freaking sweet as
Rocket would say the blog post on EA's
website says this game mocks a new
long-term partnership between the
company and Marvel games calling this
Iron Man game the quote first of several
new games this adds Credence to the
rumor that EA is also working on a
single player Black Panther game which
is not to be confused with Sky dances
Black Panther and Captain America team
up title set during World War II Marvel
really said let's make as many games as
movies and TV shows huh
and that is it for today's game spot
news what did you think of those PS5
rumors are you going to be picking up a
new Nvidia GPU let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
tomorrow on Gamespot news